what's your favorite part of the craft
uh I like the
strategies
made for artificial process yes
you want to be artificial in this world
because that's what our society is
designed for
um
no worries
conversation
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
somehow
[Music]
jobs
hanging on
yeah
well don't you think that's capitalism
and alienation from your labor thank you
mostly yeah
president
do we have any I don't know but like
what are you doing that's so bad like
what to say like you didn't decide to
have your car run into you didn't decide
to sell the restaurant so what you're
saying you're taking most of the blame
well I think I would be able to take
these punches a little easier if I had
any like foresight or uh
you know what I mean like so does that
mean you were just kind of riding out
life and not really looking ahead yeah
I'd say so so if you had all the power
in the world
um what will you be doing right now
all the power in the world all of it
yeah
I don't buy Twitch streaming dude
no I don't know wow what you don't know
you're putting the weight on what I
would do
what would you do
I would do comedy and like travel with
my friends I'd have friends
and do you feel like you don't have
friends let's start there this takes
unpacking do you feel like you don't
have friends I want to be your friend no
not really I wasn't prepared for this
type of reflection today yeah I think if
anyone here needs it we're low energy we
gotta compensate for intellectual or
that's fair how many friends do you feel
like you have like true friends and what
does that mean you have seven you
actually know them like you know the
list
the list of comedians that are my
friends no the list of friends we're
just going full friends you said seven
um
what does that mean what is a friend how
does a friend make the list of seven
well the thing is like
friendship is hard to Define
I mean I like like a lot of people and I
like hanging with them but that doesn't
mean like I'm their friends
but what do you think about life do you
uh do you think like what would you be
doing if you could be having all the
power in the world what would you do
I'm I'm kind of with you like stand Up's
the goal like I yeah I look at like if I
could raise my kid and be there for her
while also performing stand-up and
entertaining people and that provided
just enough security to maintain and
have a safe life with her that's it dude
anything over that's gravy like but that
sounds perfect to do comedy I think I'd
also
like whatever small way like I want to
do something to you know it's all about
each other
and it doesn't have to be comedy
but I think but you will be doing comedy
yeah you did say the first thing you
said was you would be doing right that's
the way it comes out for me you're right
do you think that doing do you think
comedy does help people
yeah
do you think it makes the world a better
place by laughing at all the things and
and holding the mirror up to him yeah I
mean it adds like a little one percent
boost of Happiness it's not going to do
a lot but which is why people should go
to more shows yeah yeah
towns will be in San Diego on uh I
forgot I just had to be perfect time to
plug your days
be happier improve your life by seeing
Hans Kim in San Diego yeah I mean uh
yeah yeah I don't think it's more
different than you know watching a great
movie or a live music or just doing a
fun activity you know it's something to
do that hopefully
uh makes you laugh and brings your you
know a lot of people sometimes get
offended too but that's not the
intention and I think it's a little
healthy I think a little like being
offended a little bit is healthy for you
yeah you should be pushed you should you
should question your own that made me
feel I didn't control that feel that
made me feel or I reacted to it am I
okay with how I reacted to it yeah stand
up is the one thing that if I'm like
really in the dumps that always like
immediately like a Todd Berry album or a
David tell album it's like it's funny
how like I think like all this isn't
gonna work again and it like always does
uh or Norm videos yeah
yeah and it's like more uh like
listening to podcasts kind of drains
time away but like stand up it like gets
way more chemicals flowing in the brain
for me like dude when I listen to Skanks
For The Memories it's just like or I get
to show someone that album for the first
time or something like that it's just
like really makes me happy no matter no
matter what yeah it is what happiness
is uh it's the physical
manifestation of happiness because when
it's good even if you're in a really bad
mood and you're fighting against it like
you don't need to buy in that much to
like because it's like a visceral yeah a
couple good laughs really make a pretty
strong change yeah you're like totally
changed yeah
yeah I think it's almost impossible
to laugh
and be sad at the same time to like be
actually laughing but what's weird about
that is when you have super sad moments
you will laugh through Tears like I
remember like my whole family sat around
the day my dad died and we were
literally crying and then laughing and
crying and laughing that is so true that
happened to me when my grandma died
I started laughing uncontrollably I
can't say that word
well no yeah because your body's so sad
it's like okay now I gotta balance it
out and it because it's not
it is sad but it's not sad but then it's
sad or is it always sad so
um yeah I think it's uh your body trying
to find its physical balance it's like
oh I just felt like so sad for a minute
let me just try to
temperate so that this guy doesn't just
have like a stroke right a good laugh
like that I mean releases dopamine and
other things like it's good for your
brain and stuff but I also think it's
your brain's way of being like I'm in
this
like this horrible place
and it kind of makes light of like the
that you're not in danger yeah like
you're not and also like this and also
this whole thing is stupid like your
your grandma died your dad died like
yeah you're gonna die like just like
just like that reminder of like you're
gonna die and none of this really
matters
but it Matt but like you still feel all
the feels
and so maybe I don't know maybe it's a
way to like
yeah sometimes I'm a little worried
about getting too excited about
something because I'm like if I get too
excited does that mean
um you know like the higher is gonna be
very high and then the low is going to
be even lower
so yeah K and the high B is high if the
low's not as low yeah I've been trying
to pay attention to like uh stoicism and
reading like um Marcus Aurelius I think
that helps in like you know keeping
things in balance
but uh yeah yeah you kind of look like
only what you can Marcus are realistic
I've done I've read a few books yeah the
story says I I like I mean every time I
hear stoicism quotes and stuff like that
it it makes me think that
like yeah okay all of this makes sense
well also it doesn't always feel
practical hmm yet I think that's like
the direction we should be I want to
strive towards but it'll definitely make
you in a better state of mind but will
it also produce results in the real
world because you could just be happy
and content all you want but then if
your life falls apart yeah
it's not it's not a good thing to be
that way then and is your stoicism sort
of hurting the people around you yeah
well you're like that's okay child
sometimes in life your dog dies get over
it yeah
because if you're always stoical then
it's like what is the point of life you
can't enjoy it you can't just like right
well you're content
so it's a happy medium
but his content a goal
yeah you're never gonna get too sad but
you're never gonna get too happy either
it's like living your life without
coming
but it is good to do is if you're too
emotional then you need some stoicism
but if you're like too rigid
then you need to like live life a little
yeah that summed it up I like that
it's good
what the [__] is going on I hear
something the Jeff flying over that's so
loud
people can pinpoint our location from
that
oh yeah they did that the Shia LaBeouf
when he did the flag yeah he will not
replace us yeah
what do you think about Trump going to
jail
is he going to jail I know they I
thought he's back out they like
processed them and then release them
right he flew back I thought so I
thought I some saw something where he
gave a speech like this it's just like
that they can make him do things like
come here go there well they can make
anybody do things yeah that's what they
can do yes I mean like if it's out and
he's gonna be running for the presidency
he's gonna win for sure
because every time
um I think so political whatever person
goes to jail and they get out
that seems to it helps helps help them
well how much can it help
I don't know but he I don't know I mean
people loved him before this
my dad's a big truck I love the Trump
guy yeah at times he has been since like
day one which is like funny because it's
like everyone told him he's a [__]
idiot you can't just not arrest him
because it's gonna help him like if you
have to arrest him you should arrest him
but I think it's just but are they
arresting because they think it's going
to hurt him which I think is like the
points he's making it's like this is all
happening because you're trying to hurt
me not because of what they their case
but then again that's the exact thing
you should say if there is a case so
yeah
I think uh it's just he pissed off the
people that are in charge of that and
they're gonna do whatever they can to
[__] with him
yeah I mean it's
I look at him like well clearly the
charade of politics and news is working
exactly as planned to create the most
engaging content
to keep the actual problems from getting
solved
yeah it's definitely not really
important but I mean if we're not going
to be doing anything important anyways
we might as well
make the orange man fly I don't even
understand is it engaging content like I
don't well I guess a lot of people are
engaged there's a lot of them I'm like
an outlier but anytime I have no [__]
idea what he's going to jail for
anything but I go on YouTube every day
and I search UFC MMA News and I watch
Like an eight minute daily put together
like that's way more engaging politics
are stupid always have some other
[__] they're in too yeah it's not
like anything no exactly hobby is better
than any other but the UFC the internet
is like fun to me to like be into it to
know whatever but it's like what are you
getting my dad just sits in front of the
TV you know I mean if you're gonna get
cheap like political or like uh Gossip
you might as well pick the one that hits
your brain the hardest I guess like
property owners and people who are are
with it I guess it affects them well I
mean it affects you it affects everyone
that lives here yeah the problem is I
think our younger Generations are
realizing like it really doesn't matter
who's there because nothing's like
everything seems to be going bad anyways
yeah and everyone's gotten turns
and everyone complains about the other
one and I don't know it's just weird to
me when like you look up and you're like
okay so the people that are our options
like they both like the the the our
country feels like it's like on the
verge of burning
but for some reason both of them have
matches
in their hands they're like vote for one
of us like why do you both have matches
though they're bored everyone's bored
they'd rather have a revolution than
be bored it's like if if you make life
boring enough then people want any sort
of excitement so they're like [__] it
let's blow it all up and see what
happens you think that's like that the
mentality of like the average American
like on the subconscious death wish
yeah
I mean it doesn't seem very stable
but yeah I mean I would love to uh be in
a zombie apocalypse and [__] swing
axes rather than like you know show up
for overtime and like slice onions I
think that's because everyone like they
watch shows and they think they're the
one that's gonna make it
but the in pretty much everyone else
shows like the majority of people don't
but they don't get the majority of the
screen time the act exactly yeah yeah
when they're running through the city
where there's zombies running out of
houses covered in blood everyone in the
whole neighborhood died except for the
guy you're following with the camera
yeah like he's the he's a one percent
yeah
I'd rather be the one percent physically
than financially because that seems Out
Of Reach For Me
maybe what do you mean it physically
just comes down the willpower the
billionaires yeah like the chances that
I'll be the billionaire versus the
chances I'll survive a zombie apocalypse
at least with that I can use my muscles
and do something about it
it's very Newtonian physics it's like
push a to make it go higher but now this
world is just like you know uh
Einstein's physics whatever theory of
relativity it's like uh this guy makes
this a million times more than you it's
like how do what it's hard to navigate
it with their monkey brains you mean
you'd rather be off the one person of
survivors
you got to be a Survivor than a
billionaire I'd rather be successful and
physical survival seems more feasible
in the zombie apocalypse scenario yeah
so you think your muscles
can accomplish more I think a
billionaire directed in the right
direction yeah what's your what's your
personal plan for growing these muscles
are you doing anything bad eating the
poor I have a gun how many muscles do
you need you don't want too big a muscle
you don't want to be John Cena in an
apocalypse I don't think that's going to
be a problem for you
yeah I know I'm up you're lean but like
are you are you working out are you
doing things to increase your I started
doing more kettlebell swings
yeah I'm gonna work out I'm gonna work
out because that apocalypse is coming
making adjustments
on the Fly producing as he goes I really
need to not do that but it annoys me
because like you I'm a purist yeah gotta
fix it that's why I was I have my board
right next to me because I'm like that's
like a little bit
that's a great idea
no now we're moving
so what do you think about the Dolphins
the Miami Dolphins or the porpoises
which one Ray Finkel laces out what what
are you thinking about now you're just
like word about success I'm like just
taking it all dude I'm just I'm just
simply a an observer
an observer a quiet Observer of Life
yeah what do you think about uh
polyamory polyamory uh
I don't know
you're just saying that because you're
in a relationship right now I mean it
seems like every couple that calls
himself polyamorous is like we didn't
want to break up so we're trying this
but we're just gonna we gotta do it out
of strength not weakness yeah I like the
idea but I do think you need a lot of
emotional strength especially when you
know if someone's [__] your
girlfriend exactly you get like
emotionally attached and then you're
like oh okay I guess I can [__] others
too but I'm not really getting
you know she's
getting more it's a little easier for
one yeah it seems like the closer you
get so like from far out on Instagram
when there's polyamorous couple they
post a lot of pictures they're like
hiking all the time or whatever and then
when you get more friends of them closer
with them the cracks really start to
show well I think it's good to have one
person as a foundation but I just don't
ever see a monogamous couple is really
that happy either further into it it
always seems like a little weird like
someone's trapped someone can get out
but it's trapped by guilt you're trapped
no matter what so it's like you just
trapped the word where do we trapped yes
because if you're for some couples in
some relationships yeah but if you're TR
I mean that's the thing is if you get to
the point where you're like [__] I'm
trapped like then that's the point you
should have the balls to get out
obviously easier said than done for sure
especially if you have children or like
a life
yeah but that's the one thing that like
when it comes to kids though or a leaf
or something if you're splitting rent if
it's just the money get the [__] out
like I don't know I'm speaking from two
divorces like
if you're miserable take notice and make
the change and if there's kids involved
and they're watching you be miserable
that's my personal philosophy if they're
watching you be miserable or they're
watching the the negativity that happens
between the two
they will be better off in my mind in
Two Loving homes without all that chaos
than one with two unhappy people putting
on a show for them
which they see everything behind the
scenes so it doesn't matter right and
also that's assuming one of the person
in the breakup is not going to become
even but the way things are more toxic
or yeah you think monogamous people are
happier
overall than polyamorous people or do
you think yes people absolutely
miserable I don't know I mean this is
textbook like there's certain types of
advice that I'm like since you're all
saying this I know that the other thing
is true because I hang out with my
friends and I like all my they're
[__] miserable you know what I mean
like the polyamorous ones well like that
generally what would go along with that
like a barista who has purple hair and a
tattoo yes people you know you listen to
like jocks and Instagram models
I guess I don't interact with jaws
Instagram live but uh I don't know I
guess I can only speak from my own
experience but it's like how if you have
time to invest in more than one person
on a real level then you need to find
something to pursue because it's yeah
you're not doing enough unless you just
wanted them right now live in a
community
um
I don't know I guess it works for me I
think that there's a vested interest in
uh you know agrarian societies to have
monogamous couples for like if you're
having peasants and you're like a lord
like for some reason monogamy is the way
to go it's a better control yeah like uh
whatever control
and I think like a lot of our [__] is
our infrastructure is designed for that
kind of relationship
well I guess for for me I uh
uh not only do I like I come up short in
my relationship with like
trying to put everything into it you
know I mean and that's just one person
so it's that and then even if it was
just random hooking up outside of it I
just am not super interested in it so
it's just like
you know what I mean yeah but do you are
you happy just [__] one person for
the rest of your life yeah I am
the crazy thing is that you know in a
relationship monogamous you know it's
more than sex right it's like the
connection you have with the other
person but if you go if you only look at
uh strictly on a sexual point of view
then yeah I mean you you know
then it's it's a little bit more
difficult yeah of course you want what
you can't have and of course it's pretty
far down a list of motivators for me at
this point in my life so it's like
that's like such an easy compromise but
even if it isn't about sex you only want
to connect with one person you don't
want to get to know other there you go
yeah because that's like that's the
that's the fun part like
what's the best part of a real like this
sounds weird but like what's like the
most fun part of a relationship a lot of
times for most people because they don't
last forever so I don't know it'd be
interesting to ask like people who've
been married for 50 years is like those
first that the beginning when you're
falling in love you're learning new
things it's exciting you're like I don't
know and then also it settles down for a
time period and now you're just living
life together
I mean I feel like with me and my
girlfriend it's it's just such a perfect
it's like symbiosis of everything across
all categories filling each other's
blanks whoa
all the blanks yeah
I'm shooting blanks and uh
I don't know it's like so
even when it's going bad it's like stand
up it's like I don't know I don't want
to do anything other than this so even
what's going really bad I'm just gonna
keep showing up to this
and uh
like you said oh the best part is the
beginning of a relationship I feel like
that's when you're not with the person
that's like to me the best part is every
phase of every I mean I've only we've
been together for two years now okay so
it's not you know super long but every
phase every phase you go through even
the bad phases phase like when we if we
thought or something happened the best
face is when your girlfriend is covering
come
the glaze phase but uh that's kind of
sad that you said uh even though it's
going bad you keep showing up I mean I
know you should do that for maybe you
know like let's say uh that's like the
worst part of that week but if it's
going for the like for that like over a
month I would say maybe just get out and
um sad
um like it's like a bad day in Florida
is a good day anywhere or whatever that
stupid saying is that's how I feel about
my relationship it's like it's still a
deep connection yeah it's like I would
rather do like I mean I also hate women
you know I mean it's like most women I
meet I'm like yeah they're socially rude
so with Alyssa it's just more than men
to me yeah but I'm sure for women men
are more rude to them than women but a
woman think that you want to [__] them
yeah even the ones that I don't want to
[__]
which is like okay then I I'll try not
to I'll try to express that I don't want
to [__] you so maybe that's why they act
a little differently
yeah because they're afraid of rape and
murder
I'm sure there's something like that in
the evolutionary genes yeah going on
help them survive but then you look at
other cultures and women and uh Europe
or Latin America and they're not so
anxious and wound up
and what's this what's the data here
just
common knowledge oh okay like okay don't
you think like American women are a
little wound up I don't I don't have I
don't have a lot of experience with I
guess yeah like
well I've been to Europe as a child and
it just seems like there if you're like
caught checking out a girl they're not
like how dare you yeah well I've heard
like friends that have gone to Italy and
they're like the men are like incredibly
forward in the and it's just that's just
the culture yeah but the women also
don't mind it right it's from what I've
heard it's like that's just the culture
they handle their [__] I don't know
about that but they handle it and and
that's just the cultures is it's
acceptable well I do think America is
founded by Puritans and like religious
weirdos and I think that might have had
a had a trickle-down effect on our
culture yeah I'm from New England I
think some racism the shame around even
though I wasn't raised Irish Catholic I
think there's like I feel like I'm less
uh
exit you know I would never like be a
naked or even polyamory I'm just like
less receptive of those ideas because I
just feel like there's New England
there's like a big Irish Catholic don't
[__] talk about that [__] oh yeah
it's just like miserable marriages and
just choking it down and slapping it you
just mean the shame of sex is deep yeah
it's just rooted deep even though and
it's not even like a shame but it's like
I'm not gonna walk down the street in a
speedo even as like a joke I'm not
bearing you know what I mean it's just
not and it's fine other people do it I
don't even find it that funny I mean
maybe Chris Pontius is funny but the
amount that guys think being naked is
funny it's like maybe the one out of or
ten times it's actually funny so I think
it has something to do with the Chrome
New England as opposed to if you live in
California you put a sock on your dick
and play Woodstock like Red Hot Chili
Peppers or whatever yeah and I know what
you mean you mean like you're from more
cold place yeah so your sex life is not
as rich as Francisco's yeah
um my sex life is not I mean it's okay
but you're probably more like uh open
and receptive to sex than public I feel
like in the Caribbean people are wearing
less clothes so you go to the beach it's
uh you know um I don't know pina coladas
you're drunk and things happen the
dancing's more sexual the music the
music yeah instead of like a New England
bar like a fat fog in England yeah hey
get your ass over here hey darling bring
me my chicken wings and that's the lady
yes as opposed to a beach and a woman
wearing such an ignorance
no I also feel like uh that's none of
what we're saying uh like in even if
like in in the cold if you're inside
um you're probably having more sex no
yeah that's a big thing like up in like
the Middle East and stuff and I think it
not like not the Middle East the um
Midwest yeah thank you totally different
places but like the Midwest and stuff
we're like there's a lot of babies that
are coming out of winter time because
everyone's bored it's like starting over
when you were quarantining if you had
someone with you you weren't going to
work you were probably [__] like
rabbits you know if you liked each other
um and if not that relationship is over
right and if you were alone you were
probably on Tinder trying to get cold
you know to meet somebody
What's the sex thing that starts with k
Iana
Lingus there you go
kovid what's a STD
chlamydia
wow we're really working with gas right
you guys are not really wait so if you
guys have been together two years that
means like you got together during covid
or right at the beginning uh no it was
uh April like a week after I moved here
April like two years ago during the
pandemic but it was like after the
pandemic in Texas that's right Texas
like opened right back up yeah you have
to kept a rocking yeah kept yeah it
showed up and I just started or like a
weekend to be in here which was how'd
you mean her uh she following on
Instagram because she was moving to
Austin too and then just uh
like DM back and forth hung out and wow
so she was like you're in Austin how did
she know you were in Austin uh she saw
me on someone's Story doing because I
had visited Austin a few months before
and did stand up a few times here uh and
then yeah something like that I don't
know weird I mean that's how it goes man
I don't really pursue very much I just
kind of like am around and then
eventually something happens something
sticks yeah I just [__] you know you
just post for an Instagram photo and
next thing you know you're getting late
hey I wasn't posing I was crushing at uh
Whiskey Tango Foxtrot recipes and
someone took a boomerang
yeah I think it was a still photo
and she was like that's that does it for
me right there yeah really I mean I
don't know you just kind of have to
believe that's the part about love that
[__] me is you just kind of got to
believe this this person loves you even
though you're like it feels like this is
a little easy I feel like yeah it's like
someone else yeah I mean it does it
doesn't feel like the real thing yeah
it's weird when they like you too much
oh my girlfriend's like kind of obsessed
with me so like it it does ease what
about you is she like your biggest fan
does she just thinks you know she thinks
about me all the time I mean I I love
your little podcast girls like did she
make that for you Paul no I I did that
one yeah oh okay I make I've made maybe
like a hundred podcast Graphics first
did she make you things yeah she's the
best she gets me stuff makes me stuff uh
one time she so my car often will look
like you know seen in Star Wars when
they go in the trash shoot
and uh there's like a creature
underneath it Mike that's how I look
when I'm driving around my car it's like
you just have a filthy car yeah one time
uh she woke up at like six in the
morning cleaned it got it inspected did
got something fixed on it it was like a
birthday present for me and I was just
like I almost cried I was like because I
just like I do bring something to the
table in the relationship but it's like
I am uh definitely the textbook like
our our apartment's so nice and I just
like constantly just [__] leave
things you know I'm getting better at it
but uh that is uh she's just the best
she's like you know always uh cleaning
up after you got it I like how how you
wear like thoughtful
yeah that's a better way to put it yeah
I had some uh empty water bottles in my
car and then she removed them and that
made me cry that was so beautiful you
have no idea how bad my Hans knows no I
I can I can picture it's you picture is
she the one that starts uh usually uh
sex or yeah I could say so yeah I don't
know dude I just don't I don't well I
don't know I just [__] I'm I'm kind
of like if she broke up with me I'm like
retiring my jersey as far as like trying
to hook up I just sex is just not a huge
yeah I mean it's good like we're
addicted to Adderall for a while yeah it
really [__] my did it you think so no
I just uh
I just it makes me feel like hooking up
with shakes and stuff makes me feel bad
and then this is like no redeeming I
don't know just kind of an objective is
that the guilt coming back in like if
I'm having sex with people that's bad no
it's just like uh it's all just an
embarrassing moments and uh I feel like
I've done it a lot enough for what I
should have done in this life and I just
uh I was like kind of a weird 18 to like
24 it was kind of a weird like
you know I was hooking up online before
like I'd hooked up with a girl off of
Fortran I heard of other girl off of fat
life you know I was like a weird
promiscuous [__] I'm lucky nothing
happened to me so now just like looking
back on it I'm like yeah whatever you've
had your fun maybe it's not sex that you
like but like the people
are broken sex culture like like some
weirdos that you have to [__] I mean if
you're on fet life you're looking for
something right I just like that the I
feel like this girl's gonna be the eyes
and the kill Tony alley the other day
and I just like the idea that's like
nothing like getting the ice by the
trash shoot yeah but I just feel like
they like you know someone accepts you
for one night or whatever but then
you're like uh oh that's not it's real
or whatever so that's sort of I guess
why I after like 26 27 it was like
strictly kind of Serial monogamy for me
because I like them more
yeah and like actually it being good not
it being this weird moment that you'll
either forget about or kind of cringe at
every time you think yeah I tell a sex
story uh on stage for it's like I have
no story so I roll on for a storytelling
show a few months ago and it's I think
it's like gonna be in my act and uh it's
just a weird
it's weird to like revisit those uh
those memories and remember where you
were going well I don't think we have a
very healthy sex culture I don't think
dating is very easy and I don't think
like you should just give up on sex or
dating I think you just gotta find the
right people to do it with because I
think a lot of people are traumatized
and broken in our society and then
they're out there [__] and then
people that aren't traumatized or broken
become traumatized and broken because
they're [__] those weirdos and then
it just spreads it's a vicious cycle
yeah
sex is like an indicator of how healthy
a society is and why would we have a
healthy society when we spend almost no
money on social programs
anyways and I think it's easier than
ever today nowadays because you know
now you can just go on Instagram and
throw fire
yeah you can't buy ads about dating and
then you get something started you know
yeah imagine if you could buy an ad and
be like hey I'm looking to [__] I saw
and it was on Tick Tock or something but
it was they were running stats and
apparently like they took a poll and
it's something like 56
of American Youth under the age of like
26.
aren't even looking for any type of
relationship they don't want to hook up
they don't want to get together they
don't want to get married they don't
want sex yeah they're just doing their
thing they got all these Plastics in
them yeah and their dicks are all like
weird I think it's good paints are going
away I think it's not only random sex
but relationships I think you just take
it or leave it like with kids I'm like
I'll take it or leave it if I get the
end of my life get like Millions you
know what I mean that's why and then I
found Alyssa and I was like cool like I
just feel like sex is taken care of my
advice for mid-20s kids as far as
relationships is like you know if
something happens it happens but I would
just take it or leave it it's not really
that big of a deal like I guess with
stand up for us not to be like corny
it's like yeah this is what I'm doing
and like if other things slot in around
it that's great but since I have this
thing even if Alyssa breaks up with me
and I'm sleeping in my car I'll still
have this like yeah I'm gonna be Steve
Harvey someday yeah it's crazy this
doesn't make any [__] it does a lot
for you like just the thing it's like
the only thing that that's like I'm
willing to die on that so what you're
saying is that one one day you think
you're gonna be black maybe
um I would say the only reason I would
do polyamory I think the only way to do
it is to become like Chris Rock rich and
then you're kind of in a situation where
you're like look I'm gonna have some
strange on the road but your entire
family tree is taken care of now and
everyone's and I still love you and I
love you I'll come home to you yeah but
and I feel like my girlfriend with
cosine is like yeah if you're making 40
million dollars a year sure you can [__]
other people go for it so I feel like
that's a good that's where I'm at right
now it's like that whole barometer up to
40 mil I'll be a good man and then once
I get there I'll be like look
[Laughter]
well no I think that's great that you're
saying all this stuff
I hope she doesn't listen I know Hans
and I were talking this morning and
there is something when it comes to like
comedy and relationships it's like if
you're really gonna
like relationships take time and they
take work and they take energy and
comedy takes a lot of time and a lot of
work and a lot of energy and there's no
way if you if you're trying to do both
one of them will suffer
yeah it's funny that I mean
relationships take time but uh sex
doesn't take a lot of time but then if
you're just in a relationship with a
dude doesn't do comedy like or doesn't
have any interesting hobbies or jobs
then that relationship isn't going to do
well either
because then you're dating some loser
who's not doing anything with his life
yeah I have a feeling that most
relationships where both people are I
would consider interesting because they
are interested in things and doing
things and fulfilling their heart and
like creating in something those I bet
those relationships when both people
have that and have their own thing those
last longer than just we're just like we
just both like Netflix we have a zero
drive to do anything or create or
express ourselves I think Comics like
convince themselves with relationships
like uh that it's not the
ideal you know because you have to put
it's a push and pull and there's
compromise but like I'm a victim of in
my past only looking at the cons of a
situation and using that to like make my
decision but when you objectively look
at like me and Alyssa for example there
might be moments where
I am not able to like be out as like
whatever it is right but there's also
like a whole list of Pros that I would
not have like the
support like tons of stuff like I would
literally not even if I rattle off I
would sound pathetic and uh I just think
that you know we get it I just think the
cons and Pros saying that people agree
with that is like dude you gotta look at
uh also it's like
just play the hand you're dealt or
whatever like why I I just know if
Comics that'd be like I'm gonna bring
over there dude because you know it's
like I'm doing this comedy thing I'm
like I'm not getting up enough you can
make it work dude she doesn't work on
Wall Street you're fine like you'll find
you know I feel like it's an important
part of life is uh finding someone to
connect with and and when you don't
succeed and stand up as fast as you want
to you start ever you start to think
like uh oh it must be because I'm in
this related yeah it's not it's because
well if that's all it takes to break up
with your girlfriend then uh you weren't
gonna be that solid with her anyway well
it compounds
yes what's up
where is it what are you looking for a
laptop I don't know where I put I think
I might have to put it over there
somewhere
not that one
okay okay
and actually I gotta go get ready oh
okay but yours keep going but it was
nice meeting you guys and I'm glad
you're happy I'm heading over to
Mothership with Hassan I've never yet to
be there so he's going to take me with
him show me around cool excited
all right guys
love you love you
that was James Schrader
you can catch him on
the Squatch Dr Squatch commercials
you can just go over it can't you okay
yeah go over one under the other you can
also open the door
anyways
he's crashing on our couch
see you man
[Music]
what do you think about
pedophiles
you know
I think it's crazy that uh
they uh not only exist
but uh
probably things are going on right now
as we speak nobody's aware you know I
can't believe they go for it I mean I'm
at work I don't even want to take an
extra 10 cents out of the drawer
because I don't want to get caught these
guys are just like yeah I'm gonna [__]
this kid like I have such a I'm not like
a morally good person I just like really
I'm like this is not worth it I don't
get caught doing this so I just like
follow the rules so you're saying that
you're attracted to kids but you don't
[__] them because I'm saying even if I
was I'm such a good person that I would
be the I would fight against the urge
and you know what I would do you're more
afraid of consequences I would uh I
would trap the pedophiles of the YouTube
channel that's what I would do if I was
attracted to kids you would trap a file
yeah it would be one of the Trap of
files
how many animals are pedophiles
uh you know like a dog [__]
underage dog
and they're not aware that they are
pedophiles yeah do is there a like does
an older Animal I guess not a lot of
animals just like do they see like I
shouldn't [__] this it's young is that
it exists that's a funny question that
you basically couldn't ask any normal
person but it's very interesting is
there like a moral compass in like
animals to be like no I'm not gonna [__]
that yeah like this [__] smells too
young yeah
that's funny
yeah
you have to have that or else you're
gonna waste all your good come on
something that can't procreate
what do you consider a good calm
uh like the like the tip of the dick
come
huh it's funny because I
um not not bragging but I came in my
girlfriend's mouth yesterday nice and uh
she's Peter right back and she said your
sperm tastes [__] and then she was
like I'm glad you didn't come inside of
me because I don't want to have a
[__] kid she has a sense of humor
she doesn't want like soggy [__] in her
[__]
I don't know so
I mean so she's sucked off a [__]
guy before if she knows me no she said
that my semen in that uh
that time yesterday yeah what's her
control group she said I tasted [__]
and uh
that she was happy I didn't come inside
of her because she didn't want to risk
having a [__] child
um so I don't know that's weird
it's nice to know that your girlfriend
doesn't want to retire a child because
like you can get rid of one if they find
out in the womb they'll get rid of it
but it's like you know if whatever is
too kind I would look too nice I would
like to have a [__] time like it's
God's special gift it's like what us
like not having a social life because we
have to spend every single day taking
care of this
child until he's 40 and he's a man
you know
they require a lot of Selfless Love
would you rather have a trans kid or a
[__] kid what's the difference I
mean right now
um
I would rather have a trans kid because
you can talk to the trans kid and they
might like do something cool well
they're retargeting cool art the
[__] kid is gonna be happier
that's true yeah but they're both gonna
be unfuckable but the trans kid's gonna
be sexier so if they're both gonna not
be getting late I might as well choose
the one that but we just learned today
that are there any protects is not
everything and then
um the [__] child is guaranteed
gonna be happy all the time are there
any mentally challenged trans people
like that's good yeah
um because like gender identity doesn't
play into that inspection review
I don't know
all right yeah what if they're like
[__] about their gender I feel I
mean this is kind of a right-wing ticket
I feel like General identity I'm a man
but why would I trust you you're
[__] you probably don't know what
you're talking about I feel like
generating these and this is the kind of
railing talking point but it's like when
you have a lot of time to think about a
lot of things which is cool it's cool to
be philosophical whatever the future
that's what you come to you don't come
to that yeah yeah so it's like who's the
one enforcing gender roles it's not like
the Liberals being like you have to be
trans it's like it's like nature or
whatever like when it's Republicans
being like hey you gotta be man or woman
also like life is brutal enough than
that itself and for because the roles
were originally created to sort of I
think uh like you should be whatever
whatever you want yes
um man woman that's a word that we
humans created yes um that it's part of
language you should be whatever you want
but if you if you're gonna try to
procreate
then you need to know your sexual
orientation or like your gender I'm
sorry
so like if you have a dick you cannot
procreate it with someone that has
another dick
you're blowing my mind right now you can
just sort of like hope they figure it
out we don't have to like mandate any
education or anything right so two games
animals do this right you know maybe an
animal feels safe feminine or he feels
like a like a woman
but he he wants to come inside they
always bring up seahorses I know they're
animals and look I'm fully with you but
uh it's like they always bring out like
well you know look at seahorses and he's
like yeah they're both gay looking sea
creatures like it's like they're both
girl see horses like I get that the man
yeah I mean some creatures are just like
flamingos those are both girls cats all
girls
yeah does that make sense yeah it's not
a good example of animals are just girly
like cats now if a tiger boys are drugs
if the male tiger could get pregnant
that would be like something then you
have a debate but like of course a male
seahorsing your friend look at it well I
just don't think that uh trans people
are like out to get us or anything I
think it's like uh people that were
wrong about gay marriage that sort of
like a way of thinking sort of like
morphed into like this
and they just gave up gay marriage
completely like we lose sorry and like
Chappelle or like certain you know
people will try to paint this narrative
that they're very like uh
loud or like uh you know they're
putting up it's like most trans people I
meet her there's like shot they just
really don't want to be bothered I'm
like it's funny it's like they just want
to live there lots of them are like
nerds yeah and they're just trying to
live their life like dweebs and they're
like yeah it's just funny to think that
like I think everyone is just a human
and they're trying everybody's just
trying to do what makes them uh happy
and you know it's like back in the day
if you were like left-handed they would
hit you you know yeah that actually is a
good point like trans people are the
left-handed people it's like I'm
left-handed I'm glad you know back in
the day they would make you like yeah
you know that would force you to do
other stuff
I got because I was left-handed like my
dad would force me to like suck his dick
that's a good joke it's really bad no
yeah that's actually very awful
do you think like uh your dad being
abusive is a joke that you go to because
that's true for you and you're like used
to saying that because you are familiar
with it well my the funny thing is that
I my dad you know he used to
um discipline me I think that's a better
word
um I don't think he abused me do they
have a boner
um and uh he sounds like something and I
I I love my dad you know like looking
back it's like I don't know I guess
that's what people did
you sound like a battery in the culture
you know like if I misbehaved or answer
back or something you know I would like
get healed by get hit by by a bell and
up until 40 years ago that was uh listen
I didn't see it as abuse or I mean
you know I yeah it's just an animalistic
way of communicating that we've
inherited yeah I mean I feel like I deal
with old people at my job and you're
just like I just want to punch this
woman right I'm not going to but I'm
like you know for some reason when I get
frustrated I think it's like hitting the
TV when it's not working like maybe I
just punch this person in the head it'll
start acting right
yeah to me three [__] dollars dude
breakfast waiter dude old lady running
back and forth all [__] day and I
just know in my head she's gonna give me
three dollars at the end of this
and it's just like I don't give a [__]
how old you are
I really running errands for you like
you get to the table they're like I need
this go grab it oh I actually need this
like literally four times in a row and
then it's just so annoying to just be
like you're gonna give me like such a
measly amount of money three dollar tip
yeah because it's a breakfast place so
not everybody tips like 20 especially
like old people that just get like
coffee and [__] and even they do do
tip toy percent they're not I mean that
don't you I don't know I don't know how
much they paid for like maybe they only
spent ten dollars no and that's what I
ultimately tell myself is just like uh
even if they don't tip tour it's like
you know these people came in they have
whatever money they're gonna give me
whatever money it is funny because you
you're getting the clientele that it's
not used to the new tipping
um boom that is going on because now
everywhere else you're getting pretty
much every night you tip way more
everybody's like over tipping and like
it's crazy like you go to a [__] I
don't know Whataburger and they put that
iPad and whatever I don't know if they
have an iPad or whatever it's probably
about it I go there like you go to I
don't know Starbucks where before you
you were not supposed to tip you just
pay for the coffee and then you get it
but now you have the iPad and it's like
the you know it's like there so and then
a lot of places the minimum now is like
20 percent
um yeah so uh bad thing and I remember
like paying like 20 for a haircut
um now the I don't know like the cheaper
the cheapest or I can find is like 35 or
yeah and now you should post a tip 20. I
have to get like your friends stick out
your hair yeah it's like tattoos or the
same thing as like unless you have a lot
of money like all my friends are
covering tattoos they just have friends
that do tattoos it's like a funny thing
to be like uh I get [__] dude one time
last week these uh three days came in
and uh they're like oh you are a
waitress they were [__] with me the
whole time and I actually kind of
laughed about it later because I was
like it is funny to just [__] with a
dude at his job at six in the morning
just to cause chaos in the world but I
was so [__] mad the first thing he
said are you our waitress
and I was like yeah and they just kept
saying [__] like the whole time just
like trying to [__] with me and I just
kept being like okay dude whatever
and uh
I laughed about later but I was just
like dude I cannot believe these people
are just punishing me they're like three
garbage men I can't manually they're
just saying things weird and making it
quirky yeah like at the end I was like
how was everything he's like honestly I
thought it was gonna be better so I was
like all right well if I was cooking the
food then it would have been better
sorry and like they're like okay and I
was like I don't even want me to say
like yeah I mean it's a lot to like turn
on your human brain and to ask someone
to do that without when without like it
wasn't human brain they came in there
it's like the thing that they do they're
like we go to places and all three of us
[__] with the person who's serving us
that's like I got I caught the vibe real
quick out the gate that that was what
was happening yeah well that's the thing
is like they're like hey we're just
joking around why you can't even joke
around it's like you're foisting that
upon people without
asking it wasn't even it certainly
wasn't joking like with me in on it it
was certainly that they that's what
that's the guys that they're using yeah
I went into a poke place and I was like
can I have two of the sushi thingies
and this girl was like uh
and then she just starts like picking up
[__] like what do you want now oh and
it's like I wasn't trying to be
like that I wasn't trying to be jokey
and like oh look at me I'm like the guy
from Juno I was just like
I don't know what you call your stupid
[__] uh let me get that Sushi thing did
I get the energy all the time at Vulcan
one like two or three times I dealt with
a bartender where I was just like hey
can I eat a beer and then it was just
the attitude was like am I not supposed
to
buy a beer here like why is it like
they're talking they're leaned over the
bar talking to three women and it's like
[__] it comes over to me and dude I tip
like two bucks a drink like I tip you
know what I mean and uh then he sold me
the second beer at a higher price and I
said oh this was like six bucks the last
time but I literally just said it like
that and then he went what are you
saying like you like yelled at me and I
was like never mind dude my bad I wish I
hadn't said the name of the bar but yeah
well this was like two years ago so
there's no way to like track this is
like right when I moved to Austin so
also I had pink hair at the time so he's
probably not right he left that part up
and I get that from so many people I'm
such a pushover that crucial part that
should have been like I was dressed and
looking like a [__]
idiot yeah but I get that from like I
don't know I always just I tried to
bother [__] people that are working
but they just always seem to have an
issue with me
in particular can you imagine if that
happened at the strip club you're like
can I get a lap dance and she's like oh
[__] this guy
all right
and she's giving you a lap dance
sarcastically yeah
and then you have to taper
yeah
25 yeah the bartender's down in six like
I mean I get it they're
probably hate their job because
someone's being an [__] to them
and it trickles down yeah maybe maybe
you came across like an [__]
yeah I get it stressful they deal with
drunk people all [__] day but it's
like I literally just like can I have a
beer I have like my money out I do
everything the right way yeah
right now that's why we need kiosks and
iPads this is not a job for humans to
like just meet people five thousand
times a day yeah and then have to be
polite to each and every one of them
it's like get me a [__] iPad I don't
want to deal with a person like I
shouldn't you know how hard it is to be
polite it takes a lot of energy you
gotta like look for cues and [__] and
I'm autistic so maybe I'm like biased
against social interactions but it's
like yeah this could this isn't
necessary and we're just used to humans
being like cheap labor it's like oh get
a human a lift all those logs even if
there's a simpler way to do the other
people that work in this job I can't
wrap my mind around it I'm like the only
reason I'm doing it is because the hours
I if I get offered a show I can just say
yes I don't have to think about it
because the place closes at three if
that wasn't the case I would not be
working there I'd be a waiter at night
at like a [__] LongHorn Steakhouse or
Texas you know it's like making so much
more money I cannot wrap my mind around
I mean I'm sure their schedule probably
calls for the same thing for a different
reason but it's weird to see certain
people at jobs and be like dude yeah
you're not making I'm [__] I made
like 60 bucks they were there for like
eight [__] hours it's really
miserable huh
um that doesn't sound like fun yeah it's
terrible but or like when you order Uber
Eats and then they cannot I live in a
like an apartment complex when they
can't find the yeah my apartment and
then I have to put shorts and
go down and try to find the person it's
like [__] I'm doing
I did Uber before this job and that's
even worse than this this shop sucks but
dude that grind is like what the [__]
dude it's just like it's so crazy
problems of the first world well uh you
know like a lot of packages it's like
the last mile problem like getting
things to Seattle is easy but then
getting it to the specific little place
that you need it it costs like double
what it costs to get it to Seattle
because you can bundle it together with
other stuff
and divide that the cost of shipping so
yeah I mean like the last mile is the
most strenuous part of a new breeds
delivery where you have to go into the
gate
and uh yeah that extra little umph is
like
you gotta do it I feel or bad for the
situations people are because it's like
again I I mean I'm not gonna [__]
make a 100K but like I'm only doing
these types of jobs and doing it this
way because I'm trying to do stand up
all that [__] so when I see other people
where I'm like I guess like right now
it's just not an option even if they
want the better or they're doing a job
and doing this on the side because they
just have that much of an overhead
that's really [__] depressing because
for me it's just like all right I'm just
gonna [__] keep doing this and but
this is the mean soon and all that [__]
and then you look at people that are
like no I need to like pay
whatever child support so I have to do
doordash on the side whatever it is it's
that's like really [__] dark
yeah when you need to do it because I
kind of trap myself in this so it's
easier the good thing about ubereats is
like you don't have to dedicate your
life to it yeah but any other job it's
like competition between all the other
employees to be like hey I'm uh
I'm more dedicated to this job than you
are
and it's like if you're not playing that
game then you don't like
you don't uh get invited to [__] and
they don't hire you and stuff if
anyone's losing and they just need money
go get your pest control license because
it's not like the best child in the
world but you'll get paid so much and
it's so [__] easy and it's easy to
get the license it's like a [__] it's
basically a test too because the
Landscaping industry you know with uh
Spanish-speaking people is kind of like
that's like they kind of so what they
did in Pest Control is they basically
made the tests like racist so they're
like English quit like if English is
your second language you just like
struggle with it because they're like
weirdly worded and [__] so it's just
like that which sucks but also the
bright side is they're just like oh cool
if I get a license I'm paid like this
much because it's like artificially the
the bottleneck is uh and so uh when I
was in Pennsylvania I was uh
speaking of ubereats
and Pest Control is fun too but it's
kind of
gay
yeah I mean I don't really have much
experience with that but
um I was uh getting a new breeds and
this guy was like
delivering my food and I got it and then
it was like what are you sleeping
it's like what no it's like you look
like you were sleeping and then I was in
an Uber once and he dropped me off and
it's like I'm glad you got to take a nap
I like laughed that I slept in his van
but it's like why do people act so weird
around sleeping why are they like oh you
slept you're an idiot for sleeping
you're so stupid I've never seen that I
think they're just jealous yeah because
they have to work yeah you know like you
ever are you ever like driving back from
a gig and the person next to you is
sleeping the entire time and you're
driving
and you're like [__] I wish I could be
sleeping right now no you guys were
[__]
I was just in the back seat
um no but um it's like we're at a job
and someone sees you hanging out and
they're like hey what the [__] are you
doing and you're like I'm I did all my
[__] twice as fast as you so I have a
pocket of time here yeah I'm not just I
don't think people are weird about
sleepers well that's what I'm saying is
like people see you in a this small
moment and then they just want to make
themselves feel better it's like this
guy's just sleeping all the time I
literally he slept for 15 minutes like
once yeah because this guy's yeah
sleeping when you see him so it's like
oh this guy does nothing with his life
yeah well I'm awake I never sleep but
people have to do that to get themselves
[__] weird to push yeah I think it's
like sleep deprivation talking you don't
even know they're saying it it's just
the demon yeah inside that they're like
sleep is bad I don't get sleep because
I'm a good person
but yeah I think it's every time I Uber
back from downtown I've just fall asleep
because I'm probably drunk and yeah just
pass out in the back I have an Uber in
so long Uber is a luxury yeah it is nice
but it's like I don't want to talk to
someone like I pay for a bus and I don't
have to talk to anyone yeah I pay for an
Uber and now I have to talk to you I
paid you 20 bucks
if I couldn't you just like uh
you might be able to just play the Asian
card it's not pretend I can't speak
English so Asian sorry yeah
um yeah that I literally would do that
all the [__] times I do hate talking
to people but when people talk to me I
just there's nothing I can I was like
okay and you know sometimes it's like
they don't even need you to respond
they're just like so pent up they're
just like unloading on you yeah whatever
they think conversation have you ever
seen what they rate you like yeah I got
a 4.7 I don't know what's my score on
Uber should we compare scores yeah let's
do it today do you use Lyft or Uber both
I haven't used either of them forever
yeah I usually check both see which
one's cheaper and then I go for that one
this morning
we're supposed to get people's phone
numbers at work right so that after
their meal 4.83 sorry they get a text to
review the mail how to check mine
oh I mean Uber right now of your profile
4.9 on left
so they asked us to ask for people's
phone numbers and so I asked this guy
for his phone number this morning and he
goes He yells he goes if I gotta give
you a phone number then I'm not eating
here and he turns like storms out I just
want to be like dude do you think I'm
the one
I don't want to [__] ask you for your
phone number and also if you say no I
just say okay that's all they say they
say no you don't have to put a phone
number in but you have to ask them for
it what is that they're paying me two
dollars an hour by the way so it's like
it's [__] absolutely insane they're
like here's two dollars an hour and you
get tips from customers also why don't
you start the interaction by pissing
them off
when the empty restaurant asking them
for their [__] phone number instead
of just seating them and like great
thank you for setting me up for failure
do you have a beer yeah downstairs in
the fridge do you want to get do you
want to see you is it yours is it okay
to yeah
so he's not gonna get me a beer he's not
your roommates no no it's fine he threw
up which one
the white cloth there's only one beer in
there he threw a big snake
if I get spam calls all the time it's
like all right dude well you [__] up
I'm sorry
so yeah I mean I agree with you like
giving people's phone numbers is kind of
weird
oh dude it's the worst I mean I'm gonna
find something else soon but uh
it's like they'll cut you right yeah so
I'm not getting more tables but to do
all the [__] I have to do before I leave
it at least takes an hour and that's if
I'm doing it fast and so the whole time
I'm just like and then I'm expected to
still [__] like run food if it's up
there and [__] and I just don't do it
I'm just like once I'm cut I'm just like
I literally say it like I'm getting paid
two dollars an hour right now so I'm not
helping you with your table I'm sorry
there's nothing I can do
like it's just like once I'm not making
tips anymore I have to get out of here
as soon as [__] possible because it's
my my hourly rate is [__] plummeting
every Millennial way to work well it's
just like dude what the [__] it's it's
insane it's insane yeah but don't you
think like it's like hey you're doing it
you're there
like you might as well it's not that
much more work to help out a little bit
make it look good for the company no
because
I'm good at [__] working
so even if I go at like a slow pace I'm
doing five things to every one thing
that that's almost every job I've ever
worked at and I just accept it I'll get
mad at people I'm just like everyone's
gonna do how much they can do but
standing around talking all that [__] I
just don't do that so like if I [__]
don't stop myself it's just like
I'm gonna be doing all this [__] for you
because I'm gonna get to it first and
I'm gonna [__] figure out the issue
like it's just so I just have to be like
once I'm I'm just like no I'm not doing
that yeah you don't also if you're a
good worker you have the uh privilege of
being like no I'm not doing that there's
like something you're supposed to fill
out the end of the day where you like
list the core values of the company and
[__] before you leave on the slip every
day you come in I just said no I'm not
doing that and they're like well you
have to I'm not doing that they're like
okay that's good you got to stand up
first well it's like I show up and I do
it and I try to take every part of your
soul
yeah so the trade-off is like look I'm
gonna be here and work hard but if
anything I deem is not
[__] useful at all you got to be cool
at your job it's just not useful it's
like a waste of [__] time yeah we
should give people more autonomy to do
the job the best that the way that they
see fit because if I'm happy then I'm
gonna be pleasant to customers if you
make me [__] do these things it's
like now I'm being an [__]
so uh
yeah but you know it's only temporary
because any any minute now dude my
[__] my horses are come home
do you do a lot of mics I don't see you
a lot
um Paul I try to do at least do one like
spot whether it's a show or I'm like
every night but uh I'm gonna try to get
out there more because
I definitely feel that we're like one
time last year like I saw him somewhere
and it really
hit me he was like oh are you back and I
didn't I hadn't gone anywhere and I was
just like I don't know if you were
[__] me or not but I was really like
[__] man I'm not out there doing comedy
enough honestly because I'm like out of
town well I thought the same
um because I hadn't seen you for a while
I was a very emotional worker I sneak in
and sneak out a lot like I'll go up
first Dead mics and uh but I definitely
do need to it would be better if I was
more persistent because you were saying
you're saying that you do the the job
that you have yeah because of stand up
yeah but then
um I mean I'm not telling you what to do
or not but
um
I feel like you should you should do all
the yeah all the mics I need to get into
another run of like three four spots a
night type sure like all the mics that
you can yeah for sure
um
well you know when I was [__]
impossible you sign up online never get
on that [__] [__] went to buzz Mill
six hours early signed up for standby
and then when it started I didn't see my
name on the list and you're like oh
you'll probably be able to get up to the
end I was like
why every other week is standby it's
like it's so it's just it's because it's
a big scene or whatever and but there's
also a lot a lot of mics no for sure but
it is like a [__] it's really a
headache sometimes to uh
to navigate it
um
and I just try to get a lot of work done
on like
you know I write I show up I'm like I'm
doing these 16 jokes and then I go home
and I you know I mean so I try to make
it like
not saying that because I write it home
I don't have to do as many mics but I
think like more so than a person who
writes on stage and [__] like that like
if I can write for an hour and go to a
mic do this like doing open mics makes
you better at comedy or does it just
make you good at open mics
I think
um both because we don't realize it but
there's a lot of [__] that goes on like
I think every time you get on stage
it's kind of like a muscle memory and
you're learning little things that you
that you don't know you're you're doing
um you know someone at the bar goes
crazy you react to that or you try to
get someone's attention or
um even you know you're performing
outside and it's windy or you know the
the place has a shitty speaker system
like all of these things they kind of
like I add up you get to the essence of
funny you're like what is funny in this
situation what would be funny to say to
these people in this basement exactly
with a mop I also think that uh you just
have to constantly evaluate like you
have to do it a certain way it's kind of
like uh when I used to play like video
games in terms of stuff it's like
there's playing to learn and playing to
win so like if you're in the tournament
you're planning to win so you'll do
something even if it's kind of a bad
habit because it's working against this
person ever but then if I'm in a
friendly if I'm in a friendly versus you
I'm gonna use a shitty character or
something I'm gonna try to do [__] that
I'm not good at
because now I don't care about winning
this match so with Mike's it's like you
kind of have to get away from that like
that's the thing like with Mike's like
you can get a little jaded where you're
like oh [__] this audience and you get
really good at the [__] this audience
yeah but that's not really a great thing
to have it shows
right because the [__] this audience
they're like
they're like no we paid we want it to be
good like we're trying right if you keep
trying we'll meet you but like I fed
about Open Mic you keep trying and keep
trying they're gonna be like look at
this guy he's trying I've heard a few
people talk about how like oh this many
mics are going to this religion mic
isn't helpful and then I just think
about every [__] person that I know
that I've seen personally have a glow up
and stand up yourself included I'm like
dude when I met that guy he was [__]
four times a night like it's like maybe
he doesn't do it now because he has the
other state I like doing it yeah like
that's the thing too and it's like I
need to get what I need out of that
night if I need to like work on a bit or
like I need to feel like something
happened
also I feel like when you're in a mic
and you're waiting you're you're getting
the comedy mentality so you're thinking
about jokes you're thinking about
talking about thinking about [__] on the
way there on the way back yeah you'll
listen to your sad
um and if you don't have a job you're in
the shower thinking about it all right
all your attention is on it and just
being out like
you never know like what night that
someone just books you they just see you
and someone dropped and you're there
that's like a big part of it too yeah
that I kind of fall short on although
sometimes I feel like me being out too
late is like diminishing returns like if
I'm around somebody's a little too long
they're gonna actually start to not like
me yeah they're gonna become like them
uh it really is just more like I don't
know I just feel like I always feel like
when I'm standing in a group of comics
with a few exceptions that I'm like sort
of okay well I guess you guys are having
a conversation and um you know I mean
it's like is it weird I'm standing here
I think that happens to everyone but
it's um you know a matter of uh just
being yourself and trying to have fun
like I'm also very like socially awkward
but
once you get to know people you know
most people are very nice and um you
sort of become friendly with them and
you lose that
guard or whatever you had before but
that happens all the time
the scene is another Beast navigating
the scene and the open mics and like
hanging with people that's like a
full-time job too and a lot of people
get addicted to that that's why I just
cling to like you said just like I like
doing this so it's just approaching it
like yeah I just want to go there and do
it it's oh it's shitty no one's there
I'm like all right dude I go to the
Mueller Park mine because it's just like
this is what I like doing and like even
again the worst version of it is still
it's getting me somewhere and it feels
good and uh really just leaning into
that part of it rather than being like I
gotta do this because I'm grinding and
[__] yeah it's definitely more worth it
to just be like no I like losing myself
in this for the sake of losing myself
and uh like I said dude everyone I know
that [__] is successful when I met
them they were doing like five mics a
night so the idea like some I've heard
of my comments oh you get like bad
habits I'm like dude where what are you
gonna do then you're gonna I mean it's
better to
have good habits than to have
uh it's better to have good habits and
bad habits than no habits um
and like if you do that much comedy you
get like the sort of confidence where
you're like oh I deserve to do good and
then you allow yourself to kill
the way I see it is like if you want to
be like a
you know a professional a stand-up you
know professional stand-up that means
you're probably I mean I'm I'm I'm just
speaking from what I know maybe I'm
wrong but it feels like you're gonna be
doing stand up from Sunday to Sunday
every day
so if you're an open Miker you need to
get in the mindset of just going out
every night like it's your job even
though you're not a professional yet you
know at 6 PM you leave and then you come
back home whenever you think you know
but during that time you're trying to do
mics you're trying to work on your
material
um you know I agree but I do get where
people come from because like I am
really you know like a lot of people
want to be further along than I am but
then I look especially the first few
months I was here and you know no one
booked me no one and like being in that
spot looking at the Sea of open mikers
it's like it is [__] like it's so
hard like I have friends that moved here
and haven't they can't even get booked
on you know it's like me being grateful
for like the secret group books man like
it's just not because I can be like what
the [__] like I got nothing going on and
it's like damn imagine if I didn't have
what I have like the how deflating
imagine if you were [__]
imagine if you're a [__] [__]
I'm trying to think of who I can throw
right now dude it's like mad heart like
there's no he's it's just there's a
hundred [__] 50 people there there
are there are comics in other places
that they only get access to like three
mics a week and you're in Austin you
know we have uh the advantage of having
so many mics
there's not a reason like if if you're
able to do it like don't be why are you
choosing you know staying at home just
watching Netflix with your girlfriend
I'm not saying that's what you're doing
but I was kind of like you know on a
Sunday for me I kind of rather stay at
home with my girlfriend
but I made the decision I'm just gonna
go out every night at 6 p.m yeah
um but yeah I'm not saying it's it's
better or not but that's that's what I'm
doing and I'm gonna keep doing that
yeah I think it's good to do a lot of
sets what are you gonna do tonight uh
Lucky Duck and I was lucky duck
and uh I like that okay
yeah it really was apparent to me last
week it's like you're yelling at people
yes so me and Hans went to Lucky Duck
and uh you know it's like okay so that's
especially for over Mike sets it's like
cool I learned something from that it's
just funny walking away because like oh
what do you think about that and I was
like I felt like doing comedy outside
and I was like oh yeah Hans is like
there's no reason for him to go to this
one anymore and for me it's like that's
a statement I gotta go to Lucky Dog I
love when I see when I see Hans uh
or a mic even though it doesn't happen a
lot but I love when I see you because
I don't know it just it's like you're
you're still a comic you know like if it
in my mind it's like oh he probably has
some free time and he just wants to do a
set and that's cool yeah it's like this
is where comedy happens this is where
like uh comedy is yeah and you want to
do you're the first dude that like I saw
someone
we're like oh [__] I didn't just show up
and this guy was already this I saw him
do that which is like huge for people
it's like somebody I mean [__] not
all of us are gonna do that [__] but
some of us are gonna do that so there's
something you mentioned uh you mentioned
Houston recently and uh it happened in
Houston they were doing like a mic or
something and then uh Dave Chappelle
came in and there were like five Comics
only left like it was the end of the
night and then pretty much everybody
started texting each other like holy
[__] Dave Chappelle is here and he did
like two hours you know
um but yeah it was like he just went up
that's so cool um you going up going up
yeah Ari went up at the yeah
how much time you got bro you know it's
weird when you meet someone that has
other town like for me stand up is the
thing where it's like look I am creative
but I don't think I have the ability to
do like this is the thing I'm doing and
then you meet other people and you're
like yo go [__] be a director or
something like you're [__] talented
why are you this is for like people that
have no like in you know what I mean
it's like anyone can show up you can
start doing it there's Industries where
it's like oh you went to college you
know this guy like I went to NYU and
like when I meet or Emerson in Boston
like those people doing stand up I'm
like you gotta skip from The Hamptons
don't play basketball play lacrosse or
skiing but it is awesome so I kind of
get it but also it's not awesome
did you hear about the Duke lacrosse
case
the
the fake rape yeah oh yeah I heard about
the fape
I didn't hear about it can you tell me
what happened so these two black
strippers go to the Duke lacrosse party
and they strip and then later
they get arrested
and they go to like a rehab place and
they're like fixing them up they're like
why are you so [__] up what's wrong
what's wrong and like I got raped and
then this prosecure against the case and
he's like oh let's bring down the hammer
on these [__] and they didn't get
raped they were she was just like
just a sad person that was just like
going through a lot and it was like yeah
[__] it I got raped
and they were like trying to make them
[__] a broom handle
what the [__] yeah which isn't cool but
they didn't rate them
and then they the the prosecutor made
this were they like Wing Manning the
broom handling he's a super cool guy you
should [__] my friend the broomhead
the broom handle can get laid we can all
get laid the broom handle is the nicest
guy I know man he's always there for me
I'm so [__] I'm so dumb I thought when
you said a broom handle
it was the actual handle
what of a broom what do you mean like
they wanted the girls to put a stick up
there yeah that's what I'm saying oh
okay all right what did you think that I
thought then after I thought uh broom
handle was some guy
that handles the broom and because and
because they're rich they have some guy
that just hey this guy's The Brew but
hey uh someone dropped something on the
floor called
this guy's the vacuum Handler I'm not a
janitor I'm a broom Handler
I handle the broom he's a Handler he the
broom has a lot of specific needs
yeah getting a light on uh in a in a
rape situation would be feel very bad if
that happened rape yeah
like if someone just was like outright a
lot and you're just like what because
even if people don't believe her it's
still just like why do I gotta [__]
have this in mind you know now you you
now not as bad as getting raped
yes how many rape accusations equals one
ripe
oh I don't know I would say it depends
on the rape but an average rape and an
average rape accusation I would say 10.
yeah it's just uh so if you got raped
you got 10 rape accusations you can just
go around ruining men's lives you pick
them wisely people do smaller versions
of it though like one thing that bothers
me is when you're dating a girl and
every single one of her ex-boyfriends is
like a piece of [__] and it's like no
you guys loved each other and then you
had a weird falling out and now you've
villainized him because it helps you get
over him yeah because you're a
narcissist and anyone that makes you
feel like you're not the main character
yeah is like you you violated a sacred
bond between me and my image of myself
yeah
and uh that is yeah that is crazy that
is true right yeah you are like an
incredible human being to them during
the entire relationship
and then usually towards the end or
whatever you cheat on them around and
rape them and then they're like it's
just a cope and stuff okay it's like you
can't deal with your own [__] it's like
you know me and how's it hang out for a
few months and I'm like he's not even
that [__] funny anyway dude you know
you're just like it's coping
Chris Paul you always hear like your
girlfriend gets super angry and then you
you really see what she's made of oh
yeah dude we had a fight like a few
months ago I was like our one big fight
and she is [__] saying sometimes like
what you do to someone isn't good and
it's not your fault like if there was
like a super jockey guy and I had to
hang around him all day I would like
resent him I'd hate him and I'd I'd hate
him but it's not his fault he was just
there so like just because you have this
idea of what this person is and how they
affected you doesn't mean they're
necessarily a bad person they were just
not at the right place at the right time
for you to enjoy them that's how I
navigate Open Mic so like if I don't
like someone when I meet them I I don't
like I'm just of course like you know
it's not it's unless they're a bad
person I try to just like all right it's
fine they can be this person yeah like
that's the thing about open mics is that
everyone is struggling everyone's like
trying to do something so it's like I am
on this path and then you're here it'd
be great if we could get along but I'm
focused on going to this place so it's
like it's not necessarily always going
to work out because the goal isn't to
like just get along with everyone also
like but I think it's uh
I mean this is kind of I don't know what
the word is but
at the end of the day if you if you just
like kind
it's just better than than being a dick
yeah that's just the the short answer
yeah like what don't be an adult be an
[__] being like going up to everyone
hi what's your name yeah what's your
Instagram handle yo let's connect I love
it yeah because that's fake right and
then people are so kind not self-aware
like so in that and kill Tony like if
someone when they used to Vulcan you can
watch the sets if someone up there it's
like their first time ever and they were
[__] awful people get like mad in the
pit they're just like [__] angry oh
this guy blah blah and it's might be
like dude he's allowed to sign up that's
the only reason that we're [__] here
it's just it's either all of us can sign
up or we're not getting on the show so
like getting mad at this guy it's like
that's why open mics are great it's like
everyone can [__] sign up and yeah
does it suck to follow four people that
like debatably are like mentally ill and
just scream you know I mean it's like
yeah but that's that's what's the beauty
of like you don't need a credential or
whatever so getting mad at someone for
that is just like bro if they had a
[__] sign up sheet that only certain
people invited we would be here
we wouldn't [__] make the cut so like
you have to accept that there's gonna be
people who get up there that are also
it's like you're just gonna bomb as well
when you're up there and you know
speaking of myself too it's like funny
when people get mad if it's some of her
bombings if I was up there dude I
[__] kill and it's like I don't know
dude
I don't know if it's gonna go that way
for you I don't know
um like
we make a huge deal about stand up yeah
and like just remember why you started
doing it
it was just like uh it was fun yeah but
now we we do you know a sun cost
I've invested too much in this for to do
anything but make me famous
so are you doing stand-up just to be
famous no you're saying that mindset
about her that's a good perk of it
that's a good side effect of it but it's
like I need so much from it now I've
invested so many marbles into it like if
it doesn't do everything for me then
like there's so much expectations now
because it's like been such a large part
of my life
that if it doesn't pan out then it's
like
uh my life has been pathetic
are you already winning like
by us performing in front of yeah I'm
winning 300 people I'm doing great yeah
but like so that's my point like you
know you do an open mic in front of 40
people say I lucky though yeah and then
you do a show in front of 40 people at
some other venue that it's also Outdoors
but it's like I got booked at a show
like you're going up do you have 40
people more as significant as the impact
that you make on people and the way they
look at you like oh my God you are so
amazing yeah no it's like at the end of
the day I mean you started doing
standard because you
you know whatever and then you have
ideas that you want to communicate to
people
and you like to talk to people
I mean the point I'm trying to make I
guess is like I think uh being famous or
whatever saying you want to be
successful it's uh
worthless yeah you're already successful
today if you like doing it and you enjoy
doing it and you went up in front of
people someone who's gonna like a
carpentry like you're not doing it to be
famous you're doing it because you love
carpentry and you want to do it well
there's some of that in stand-up where
you just want to get up and do well you
want to do the art form the best way
right so what's the what's the rush
I'm almost like talking to myself
yeah just take your time enjoy it
talking to an audience it's such a
beautiful precious thing that we can all
have discipline and pay attention I do
try to tell myself that is even at like
I'm open my it's crazy like it is cool
everything else aside they're gonna give
me this microphone they don't know what
I'm gonna say I can [__] I could say
some [__] you know what I mean and uh it
is cool I don't believe you even at that
lowest level that they say some [__]
right now do that and it's grateful you
can't say it you can't [__] [__] you
can't say [__] anymore
that's what I thought you called the
broom Handler the rag [__]
I don't get it the broom Handler that's
dudes drinking white Claw
is that a janitor broom handle or ragfag
yeah
um
yeah so you know uh I I will say being
kind though helps because I feel like
people would have much more of an issue
with I think loving Humanity helps and
kindness is a broad byproduct of that
yeah I don't know I don't even love
Humanity but I'm kind to people just
because it's like I love the concept of
a human I just had good parents it's
like a basis basic human base model is
like that's a good thing
and if you have that love for like just
base Humanity then you'll love yourself
because you're like oh I may I meet the
minimum requirement to be awesome
that I respect in others but if you hate
just people you're gonna be like Oh I'm
just a person oh I gotta wash my [__]
again I'm so dirty is there a tiny child
screaming in the background okay why do
you not like listening to me talk I like
losing your dog it's like what else is
going on no it's just
all right I love listening to you Tom
well why don't you respond to things
that I say instead of just oh I brought
a I brought a bottle of whiskey that I
left in my car okay should I get it sure
I feel like I'm just are we gonna get
drunk
yeah I feel like I'm kind of Prior Pizza
yeah
I'm gonna go get the bottle but it's
like a tan it's half a bottle
um I've never played but I can watch you
guys
so what do you think about the uh whole
comedy scene
I think it's amazing
I think it's very cool
all right close that door I think it's
very cool and I think uh
you know it's [__] it's hot it's hot
it's [__] happening and uh
I just hope uh
you know Pokemon where you gotta get the
ticket to the ssan before it leaves I
just hope I find my ticket before
[__] the ship set sail you know what
I mean that's all moving but if not I've
come to grips with it you know I'm
really not like bitter just because it's
like I don't know man if it doesn't it's
like it's more likely not than will so
it's like you gotta just well I think
doing comedy is fun so even if you don't
make it yes you got to do comedy and
talk to people which is what it really
all boils down to even if with all the
fame and the money you can't like derive
that as your source of energy because
that's toxic Fuel and it still led me to
like meeting Alyssa Joy comedy at the
end of the day if you're doing it right
anyways yeah it's it's already
given me a lot of lifelong friends and
all that so yeah it's like a cult you
got friends in every city and there's
people that will trust you implicitly in
a way that most people won't understand
yeah just go to an open mic do like some
five shitty one-liners and then after
the set they're like okay he's one of us
yeah there's some weed here some alcohol
do you need a place to crash yeah
do you think I'm obsessed with failure I
think you're obsessed with
not trying to fail as much yeah
well you know
okay now we're taking questions please
ask questions in the chat I can't really
imagine how much they hated this [__]
apparently the wide angle is the best
angle see I came in here trying to be
myself I said I'm gonna be myself on
this one dude and then you see what
happens everyone
it's [__] awful
uh well I think that uh you did great
and thank you we're all doing great yeah
and ultimately with podcasting I've
learned it's just gonna always feel
like once you turn the lights off
there's no end of plotting at the end
while you walk off so you've got like a
conversation yeah
and dude I mean it's I listen to these
types of podcasts like the I love craft
and [__] like that but I just know that
like uh
you know I just feel like people roll
their eyes sometimes they're like you
know I don't know I probably think too
much about yeah I I don't respect those
people yeah
because it's not like they're doing
anything it's not like they're doing
something better they don't have an
alternative they're alternative is to do
nothing and to Decay and die I'd rather
be doing something and getting better at
it than just like making fun of people
and uh you know [__] you never I
think it's cool to like
change someone some the kid at my work
went to an open mic he didn't even tell
me he went to open like in San Marcos
and it's just cool that he just like
heard I did comedy and he just went out
and did an open mic and I was like
really he's like so many of my friends
have said they were gonna do that and he
just
it's cool when everyone doesn't have any
water
so yeah what uh what do you think about
drinking you want to drink a lot right
now a little bit I'm not gonna partake
but I I'll watch again you don't drink I
do just not tonight okay
thank you
you want it with a little bit of water
or no yeah
or just on the Rocks just give me
whatever you're getting
so
what do you think about Trump going to
jail
dude I don't know the syrup
that looks so alcoholic the way it
trickles out
is it clogged
anyways I think it's like a flame uh
thing
what like Bacardi 151 has like a it's
like a I don't know
I don't know the [__] I'm talking about
I don't know why I said that like I have
any [__] idea yeah it's a foggy
[__] sugar
so uh
uh let's talk about Francisco one of the
most unique one of the most unique
comics in the Austin scene cheers man
seriously thank you for having me on
your podcast thanks for coming on my
podcast
why is there so much [__] eyes this
Ice is like attacking me it's a
Venezuelan that is true I think that's a
Venezuelan thing
where you put a lot of ice I mean that
ice would cost ten thousand dollars in
Venezuela how dare you waste so much ice
Miracle eyes
yeah um
someone's Mexican as if they use too
much ice Venezuelans love ice Mexicans
hate ice
no but um it's it's funny that you said
earlier how you had like problems or
trouble sometimes talking with other
Comics because
um whenever like since I met you you
were one of the easier guys to talk to
thank you yeah I feel like every time I
run into each other it's always really
nice and then I feel bad that I don't
reach out to hang out with you outside
of stuff yeah because you hate yourself
more than any other comic really I take
that as a best like imagine honor not
that you hate yourself better than other
Comics you hate yourself more than you
hate other Comics so like when I talk to
you I know that you're not gonna attack
me because you're not like oh I'm
awesome you're like oh yeah I suck I'm
stupid I'm dumb I'm gay
so it's like safe
yeah thank you I I uh I like
I played Smash Brothers for a long time
tournaments I was in bands and so you
know that's kind of why I [__] maybe
think of too much about trying to
succeed is because I'm just like I've
I've climbed a mountain and not reached
the summit twice and it was just I'm
just like yo I gotta [__] I gotta
make this one work like like a [__] I
don't want to get this how does that
impact the joke writing and the stage
because I feel like thinking like that
would get in the way of
the actual process and the actual doing
of it if you needed to be that
successful I would say like just enjoy
doing it because I did so inherently
enjoyable thing to talk in front of
people because we're social animals
so how much are you thinking about
success
I mean in the day-to-day probably not
much I'm mostly just doing it I like
writing jokes and telling them let's do
it like a Blog about how
sad your life is
yeah you know what people reshan like
that and then I thought about you
reading it and I was like uh he probably
thought it was [__] gay I liked it I
think it's great I think a Blog it gives
you like an insight into a certain like
personality trait or they're like their
their life isn't just in the moment it's
like a larger picture
you can connect to your audience or to
others yeah and I just take shots in the
dark with everything now because it's
can you tell can you give us a glimpse
of the things that you have written uh
recently uh topics or
okay we're taking questions in the chat
or anyone asking any questions make it
happen
yeah check my blog out yeah but um I I
mean I know you guys
um and I like you guys but I don't know
you I don't know you guys a lot like I
want to know like where you're from and
that kind of thing
um what made you like pursue stand up
yeah and uh
yeah that's why that's why I'm asking
about your blog what are you talking
about there I just wrote a uh
a thing
and then I read it back and I kind of
liked it so I told someone it was just
about black you're
about what uh just doing stand up and it
was like centered around when I was like
kill Tony last week I burned [__] out of
my head and uh that is good luck yeah
that's what they say that's what this
Vlog is about yeah so and you know
that's good luck what does that even
mean like who decided like is it just a
coping mechanism for people that got
[__] on yeah and why are we spreading
this yeah I don't think I don't think
that's true and lying to ourselves
yeah yeah but you know your uh dad dying
that's good it means you're gonna have
seven years of sex
yeah and then you're like oh I'm happy
dad died because now I get to [__]
yeah like why do you want to associate
those two your dad I think it's just uh
what if you're just like it's just a way
of humans to make things you know easier
and make light off because yeah getting
shot on a bird is not good you just got
really bad luck yeah that a bird [__] on
you and then I sat there and I was like
until you went up and you bombed I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get called and tell
them that version on my head it's gonna
be [__] great and then you just don't
get called and you're like oh yeah
that ain't how it works that could also
happen in life where the worst possible
situation happens and that's all you
need to be delusional and be like
I am still the main character I mean I
wrote like a 2000 word Blog the pitying
myself so I think it's very apparent I
think I'm the main character for sure
well yeah I mean everyone should think
that way and then make awesome art about
it instead of just everyone's just not
being the main character and just yeah
contributing little iPhone cases you're
like one of the only people that should
have me if if you would [__] on me about
doing my Vlog I would not immediately
say yeah I wrote more that night than
you have in a [__] year suck my dick
you know what I mean but they're just
like
so if you if you had to describe
yourself in one word which word will you
use
I have no idea that's tough Melancholy I
don't like that it's a cerebral really
cerebral you you think so yeah
I hope so because what else do you have
if you're not in your brain you're not
what else have you got going on
not much dude not much I thought I just
I think uh I think uh you're You're
great and you should uh I think you're
right thank you man but you should do uh
because I do that too
um what you're just white no uh you're
just a little bit more vocal about it
like you're you [__] on yourself a lot
yeah he's an expert so your self-talk is
shitty oh it's really bad I think you
should uh ask for that I think you
should uh just talk nicer to yourself
and be kinder to you yeah I should yeah
do you want to do that now I don't know
how to say something nice about you
honestly it's like myself at this point
I feel like if I had changed in my early
20s something but now it's like I'm just
used to it I don't think it like harms
me that much it is [__] up though when
I'm driving around like I'm a [__]
idiot [__] me but it doesn't really oh
the [__] it's kind of numb now so uh
I feel like it's not that big of a deal
and it's so funny talk [__] about
yourself and your Boston accent yeah oh
yeah okay yeah let's do one time when my
friend got in the car I said people with
accents [__] loose I was in Boston
during the blunt ride my we got a car
accident and my friend got out of the
car and he's punching himself in the
face going how [__] [__] is
finding himself in the head uh and his
dad used to abuse him so it was like
he's just like get down
oh [__] you're [__] and the guy who
is just a little rear-ending thing and
the guy was like it's fine
whoa you're acting kind of weird right
now it's like it's like not a big deal
yeah something goes wrong in your life
and you're just like yeah I knew this
was a little [__] accident it's gonna
feel horrible oh for sure well the kid
ran to the back of me I didn't even
report to my insurance the worst part
about the cat the car accidents are when
the other person is dead you know
yeah like uh Caitlyn Jenner oh my god
dude imagine [__] killing I know
someone that's such a funny way to kill
someone because you rear-end them into
traffic so all it takes is just like
that little poop
and then that's all it takes to murder
someone it's crazy that we have a system
built on personal cars and what can you
do in seven years of life to a town for
taking even one life you know what I
mean it's like you are net negative now
for being alive congratulations congrats
starting now you're a waste of space you
brought stuff right up on the planet
that's why I'm not touching my car like
I'm leaving my car here and I'm coming
tomorrow to get it oh yes yeah because
I'm I'm drinking now okay
um and I had it weirdly legal to say
that right I had a I had a vwi you did
yeah damn dude you got this mess
um but yeah that made me realize uh it's
not worth uh taking the wheel when
you're drinking because you're driving
is so crazy it's so crazy we make
everyone do it this is not a sustainable
way to transport people you know how
easy it is to transport people and to
think that everyone needs a car to do it
it's crazy it works as well as it does
well what is crazy is that uh the United
States supposed to be the best country
in the world yet our public
transportation system sucks yeah because
we are trying to we're also a giant [__]
over black people yeah but we could make
it like it's the United States of
America they could make it happen I know
but you know to be my dad would be like
layover America over the European you
know it's a [__] giant country but we
actively destroyed our public transit
can we at least get a [__] train from
like downtown Austin imagine a trade
between the three major cities here San
Antonio Houston and Dallas yeah that
would be so convenient like that road
trip animation awesome well it would go
through Austin okay to go you know from
Dallas to San Antonio there's not much
of a Detroit philosophical insect I am
it's like you guys talking about this
obviously be a huge thing for so many
people but literally all I can be like
yeah I could do comedy without driving
now it's the only thing I guess all you
have to do is get an Uber and people
that's kind of good because if
everyone's pursuing their own thing then
the common interest of like someone's
maybe they're not doing comedy they do
another thing is like if everyone's just
going after something it will improve
the world because we'll be like oh we
gotta make you know what I mean like uh
even though it is like selfish or
anything that way if everyone thought
that way about their own industry it
would like everything would get better
or whatever they're doing just be like
yeah but then it's like Texas you know
oil you want people to drive cars
because
cars need gas gasoline
and all that it's a whole different deal
so yeah and the problem is when most
people get over the hump
that's why I like I mean Hans bringing
up [__] is like sometimes it's a bid but
other times like it's cool because it's
like as soon as I get over a hummed if I
do I ain't [__] look maybe like [__]
you guys I got a car I'll give a [__]
about this anyway that's how everybody
is you know and then that's why things
don't you know you go like well even if
you have a car it's annoying to drive it
and park it every day yeah and if you're
drinking you cannot drive it but it's
it's also nice to drive a helicopter
everywhere
you don't think so no what about like
every time you go on your boat
boats suck too
well I like cars it's what about a jet
pack like it'd be cool to get everywhere
in a jet pack but that is I feel like
Paul would be in a yacht and he'd be
like man my life sucks yeah I'm an
artist it's too big for me I'm an artist
uh I don't like the jacuzzi with so many
Russian strippers I don't want to cheat
on my girlfriend no dude as soon as I
make it I'll be happy that's everything
you know it'll fix it what is making it
for you bro uh that's what I know
you know it's to speak it I just want to
be [__] doing it like the real way at
a club like whether it's some other [__]
you know I mean it's like not even about
like not having a side day job or
whatever but it is about like uh
being uh you know it's like can show up
to a show I'll be like can I do five
minutes you know it's just kind of like
being at that upper echelon of like
so that I can do it better and I can I
do work on a full hour and all that [__]
but I know it's uh
you know what I mean I don't know I
don't know what you mean but I think
this is what I think you mean
um you want to be at a point where you
could just go to any comedy club and
they know who you are and you could get
stage time I want people to think you
want to perform in front of a real
audience every night instead of empty
chairs and an open mic and then get
shipped chairs and empty table I want
people to see how much of a g heart that
I know I am that's really what it is I
want everyone to finally so you want to
be famous
uh no I just want to be good at this
thing well do you want to start a
revolution I don't know it's just like
uh we we complain so much and we don't
know what we want
I want to do it
for workers to be compensated for their
labor fairly
collective bargaining
I can't say what I want because I wanted
to be hedorga I had the Sunset Strip
Club and that seemed like a pretty
[__] accessible goal and I couldn't
even do that so it's like I dreaming big
for me is over
that's not a reason to so when you were
a little kid you were like I wanna be
opening doors oh dude I was I was like a
door guy dude I can't get anything going
but no that's kind of your like my
girlfriend my girlfriend you told my
girlfriend but you are talking like [__]
to you you can
yeah I know yeah I mean just you're a
very funny guy you are an incredible
writer yeah I heard you but you [__]
you don't do as many questions you
should be hitting all the [__] mics
that you can you're [__] hilarious I
love your your writing yeah
you should talk to you right like
Riley is great all right I will I will
start doing that Francisco what's up I
I'm I will yeah
stop talking [__] to yourself and
[__] do what you're doing you're
writing but now [__] present it to
people who's instead of being a girl
you're just gonna do one more guy do
your favorite sign up online and then
who do you think is working hard right
now who do you think deserves it the
most right now I don't think it's about
deserving and I think it's about earning
it like being funny if they earned it
you you there okay you [__] earn it
thank you but one of the besides of me
like in this scene right now I want to
think of a good news I think the hardest
hmm
I mean one thing one thing I will stand
up is like yeah yeah you could work very
hard but also yeah who's working hard
Mikey Biggs I feel like Mikey Biggs is
the dude that gets some do but not
nearly enough and as far as working hard
he does that as far as being hilarious
he does that and also
I love him because he's just unique I
tell him this like my jokes have like a
logic to them so I often write jokes I
think I've been written before he says
the weirdest [__] ever he just says
things that like sound or feel funny
which is kind of like he reminds me of
Chadwick not like that he's like
mitchever but that whatever he's saying
is like oh I've never heard anything
he's not tied to logic yeah and I love
that because it's like you might swing
and Miss more with new bits like that
but when you hit one it's yours and no
one's ever right I like that uh he
seems like he's having fun and he's a
very likable yeah and also he's very
funny yeah
um I saw Mikey weeks do a roast
oh
and uh he's he's just like he's very
likable his delivery is very funny I
didn't realize how good his delivery was
until in our roast the biggest laugh was
him saying Paul ciphers looks like a gay
guy and a [__] a crowd erupted and
it's like he's just saying he's like got
the thousands of years of white
supremacy just boiled down and just the
humor part he's like the [__]
hippocampus of colonialism him Jack and
miles are all very talented in their own
rights and I like them a lot I wish I
was better friends
thousands of years of like
leisure time he's been able to craft his
whiteness he's very Zen too like he's
just doing it weapon like he just does
it he doesn't over you know like he's
very much the antithesis of like what
I'm struggling with sometimes he's just
like I don't know just keep doing he
told me that one time he's like I hope
you don't quit because
you're funny but you seem like a dude
that would quit he said that today
and I was like yeah it's either you're
gonna quit it hurts or you're not gonna
quit yeah because you're gonna torture
yourself so much if you quit that you
don't quit so it's like you either way
it's gonna be miserable it's funny
because I feel like we stand up because
you're not necessarily you don't have a
boss every day you don't if you didn't
do it one day you quit for that day
shout out to Robbie Schrader Robbie do
you have any questions for the three of
us we're going to answer any questions
starting now
uh Ricky Brown asks Francisco do you
enjoy
uh the whole Austin comedy scene or are
you more a fan of
the
uh Leisure and fun of just not working
and just like would you rather just not
do anything yeah read anything you're
making this question
[Laughter]
um so I I became an engineer and I I
hated my job
but we all hated your job I know but but
uh stand up
um it brings a lot of joy and it makes
me very happy and I've never had I've
never done anything that brings so much
excitement in my life yeah I can see the
problem solving of it this is like
probably dorky to say but you being
engineer now you say that because I see
your eyes working when you're thinking
about a bit like off stage after you
just sit here about to do it whoa I see
you you're very much like a problem
solver with your bits like you're a
little conniving how can I make this
work how can I make this land a little
easier like you're always calculating
there's there's multiple parts to like
some of your longer like darker [__] and
it's uh it's like you put stuff in the
right place to make it work overtime I
always see that and that makes a lot of
sense
yeah um I I love Austin the Austin scene
but
um yeah I haven't really been in a lot
of other scenes I've been in Houston
that's where I started
and before that I did my first mics in
Shanghai it's [__] cool to think that
like this is on par yeah I mean I'm
speaking from just like looking out for
the outside but like New York La Austin
I just feel like it's pick your you know
what I mean I feel like they all have
pros and cons they're the same thing
they're a large and like I know it's
cool to just think like if I'm getting
ahead a little bit here I'm getting
ahead a little bit in like one of the
biggest problems I had everywhere and
the biggest comedy scene you know what I
mean does your girlfriend
oh she gives the best head yeah yeah
how how do you know he's a best head
like I've had a lot of hat this ranks
among the best
does that mean you come faster or you I
come fast every time enjoy it more I
come Oscar Wessel asks Francisco did
your family have enough electricity to
see her kill Tony set
David not also they did see it
eventually but they don't speak any
English so I told my mom I was doing a
TED Talk for engineers did they wonder
how someone uh
because they're very disappointed they
think I'm gonna have a band behind you
they're gonna they're thinking I'm gonna
quit being an engineer and I'm just
gonna be a homeless dude you know
but uh yeah they didn't have electricity
so you have like a pressure from your
family at all like from uh
yeah I mean I'm uh you know
I'm old enough where I can do whatever
what I want but my parents wanted me to
be an engineer
and that's why I feel like a fun
engineer because my parents are dumb
like me they're just like my boys in
Show Business like they just if I ever
[__] did like a theater they would
[__] their minds would explode
because me doing a [__] Brewery in
Massachusetts in front of 80 people is
like oh my God he's yeah it's actually
cool to have parents that'll like my dad
always sends me clips of Joan Rivers the
favorite Comics is Joan Rivers yeah and
uh it's just very funny Facebook I wake
up everyone do another Joan Rivers clip
I haven't seen before very important
yeah
I'm trying to imagine I'm watching Joan
Rivers with your dad
dude you would you would love my you'd
[__] with my dad so much like uh it's so
funny my dad comes to a comedy show
because he just like he doesn't speak up
that much but I'll say one little thing
and then it's just I've seen him
tortured by uh
I don't know he's just a really right
one guy okay yeah I can tell sorry I can
tell my parents like hey I'm doing this
crazy comedy show and they're like oh
yeah but when are you gonna get a job as
an engineer have you been interviewing
when you know are you gonna prepare for
your interview you said you had an
interview tomorrow for them it's like
survival yeah
and uh it's like yeah you need to think
about your family and your kids and and
I had to tell my mom which sounded kind
of mean I was like Mom what if I told
you that I was never gonna be an
engineer again and also I wasn't gonna
get married and also I wasn't gonna have
any kids
for her things in life for her one all
the most important things in life for
her I know and for her she it was like
pretty hard and then I'm like oh I'm
joking I'm gonna have a cute one
yeah well
kids what kind of stuff did you accident
engineer
mechanical engineering what is it like
what like give me an example like uh if
you these if this cop you need to select
the proper uh material
um and you know you design you're gonna
want something that doesn't degrade over
time so did you mostly do cups or were
you more I'm just trying to do like a
simple example what were you working
with I'm a [__] so he has to speak I
was working with uh Power Products
medium and high voltage
electricals and leaf blowers no like uh
Transformers anything you would see in a
substation or like an Optimus Prime when
you're driving you look at the power
lines everything you see in the power
lines that kind of things and electrical
motors and generators
so very fun stuff you know so you're
like what material do we need to make
the substation and you'd be like oh we
need wood
it's a lot like playing Settlers of
Italian no it's like oh look they're you
know the the motor is gonna be going at
this speed so it's gonna get very hot so
you're gonna need this type of metal so
the heat transfer blah blah blah a lot
of boring [__] so you were doing why
don't they already have that all mapped
out they're like okay we know know what
what material we need for substations no
I guess uh because uh it's that that's
just one example but sometimes like you
if you have like uh if you're Shale and
you're pumping oil from the ground
to the Gulf of Mexico yeah so like every
every project allows BP
every project is different and the every
application is different so you need to
evaluate what type of you know
uh oh we're building a substation in
Alaska we need more yeah so in that case
uh it's in that yeah right so in that
case the weather is going to be way cold
we could power the world yes but you
need to keep your oil from freezing so
you need a certain type of so all of
this is very boring and that's why I
don't like to do it insulated oil yeah
so you did oil too
okay well what do you want to say one
swear word and then let's end the show
hmm
I don't know
I think this door keeps up
this house is haunted I want to say
uh thank you thank you for being you
thank you for being you
[Music]
thank you
got it all noises
all right what are we doing tonight
okay thank you thank you guys
I'm sorry for what
I brought the team down
when did you grab the cup and put it
there how long has it been since you did
that I don't know why because that's how
long the delay is uh